Speaker 1: I'm going to play a couple of clips
for you here of a statement and an interview
that. Donald Trump produced and gave a few days
ago in relation to what's going on in Afghanistan,
and I have to tell you, if a Democratic president
had downplayed 9/11 and Osama bin Laden the way
that Donald Trump does in this interview,
they would be getting covered on Fox News
as unpatriotic traitors 24 hours a
day, probably for a week or longer. OK,
let's take a listen to this first clip. This
is Donald Trump on the Sean Hannity program.
Speaker 3: Look at al-Baghdadi. He was the founder
of ISIS. We took him out. Nobody could find him
for 15 years, far bigger than Osama bin Laden,
far bigger. Osama bin Laden dead. And he hit,
you know, the World Trade Center.
And it was a horrible thing. But
al-Baghdadi was the founder of ISIS.
Speaker 1: So there is Donald Trump
downplaying 9/11, saying the what what's the
core of this? Obama got Osama bin Laden and Trump
wants to say, I did better. I did more, as well as
justify the idea unfounded, that had he overseen
the withdrawal from Afghanistan rather than Joe
Biden, it would have gone much better. We have no
evidence to suggest that everything Trump did
turn to crap. So there's no reason to suggest
to believe that Donald Trump would have handled
the retreat from Afghanistan any better than did
Joe Biden. But Trump is downplaying the
importance of Osama bin Laden's capture and kill
being killed and downplaying by virtue of doing
that 9/11. If a Democratic president did this,
they would be they would be calling for the
head of such a Democrat, Donald Trump. Also
during this interview talking about ISIS, which
sounds like a band more than a terrorist group.
Speaker 3: Take a listen to this. And ISIS,
as you know, I knocked out 100 percent of
the ISIS caliphate. I knocked it out in
Syria, Iraq. We knocked it out so that
they have a new ISIS called ISIS. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So I actually I'm trying to
think back. I might have gone to high school, in
fact, with the with the bassist for ISIS. Anyway,
here is Donald Trump. Then in talking about ending
the war in Afghanistan, he actually says he did
want to keep troops there. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: But we had to get out with dignity.
We had to take our 80 billion dollars worth of
equipment. We had to do all of the things that,
you know, we had to do. And then I would have
blown up all the air bases, but I would have kept
Bagram because Bagram is located right
next to China, right near China and Iran,
and it's in Afghanistan. So we had the whole
group covered. They spent 10 billion dollars
building it and we handed out the keys.
Speaker 1: So understand how amazing that is
for all the talk about Trump was going to get us
out, which he failed to do for all of that talk.
And then now the criticism, which I think is
a fair criticism. I don't want Biden sending
people back in. But for all the criticism of
his criticism of saying Joe got us out and cause
chaos, but then he's also not really getting
us out because he's sending people back in.
Trump is admitting there, I would have kept
people there to keep Bagram. We would have
done it. So even Trump's full removal of troops
from Afghanistan, he admits there would not even
actually have been a full removal. And the most
important point here is there's no empirical
reason to think that Donald Trump would have
done a good job. There's no historical reason.
Last thing, Trump put out a statement about
Afghanistan, one of these direct to camera things,
and it was published on Fox News's Sean
Hannity program. Why? Maybe because Trump
has lost access to all of his other platforms
for spreading disinformation. I don't know.
But let's take a listen to a little bit of that.
Speaker 4: As One Nation, America mourns the loss
of our brave and brilliant American service
members in a savage and barbaric terrorist
attack in Afghanistan. Yeah, these noble American
warriors laid down their lives in the line of
duty. They sacrificed themselves for the country
that they loved, racing against time to rescue
their fellow citizens from harm's way. They died
as American heroes and our nation will honor
their memory forever. I want to express my deepest
condolences to the families of those we have lost.
Today, all Americans grieve alongside you.
Together, we also pray that God will heal the
other courageous American service members
who were wounded in this heinous attack.
In addition, our hearts are with the families
of all the innocent civilians who died
and with the many men, women and children who were
terribly injured in this act of evil. This tragedy
should never have taken place. It should never
have happened. And it would not have happened
if I were your president.
Speaker 1: And of course, it almost
certainly would have happened if Donald Trump were
president. So the important. Points here are, as
I mentioned, at the top of the show, this is the
perfect story for Monday morning quarterbacking,
getting out of Afghanistan was the right decision
by Joe Biden. It was a decisive decision and
predictably, it led to chaos. Go back to my clips
about when Donald Trump is looking at doing this,
if it predictably led to chaos and tragedy
and death. And that has to be dealt with.
And Joe Biden has a crisis on his hands. But
this idea that Trump would have done it right
is an absolutely pathetic, bogus idea for which
we have no evidence at all. Just there's simply
no reason to think Trump would have handled
this well because he handled nothing. Well,
we'll have more on this on The David Pakman Show
Instagram. Find us there at David Pakman show